could you imagine Dumb and Dumber with a
couple of Amigos how about Ghost Rider
and Dracula could a certain SNL Legend
have been the Cable Guy these are the
what if casting Tales of Jim Carrey
movies
it's hard to imagine anyone besides Jim
Carrey playing Miami Pet Detective Ace
Ventura the role that shot him to box
office stardom in February 1994. however
at the time that producers were casting
the role Carrie actually wasn't the
first one they approached as it turns
out Rick Moranis of Honey I Shrunk the
Kids was offered the pass but he
ultimately passed Moranis had
established a successful acting career
during the 80s in the likes of
Ghostbusters Spaceballs and Little Shop
of Horus but by the time he was courted
to play Ace Ventura he was intentionally
taking fewer roles after his wife
ambelski died of breast cancer in
February 1991. by 1997 it essentially
retired from acting to raise his two
kids although he occasionally did
voiceover work and other creative
projects for runners ultimately never
regretted taking this Hiatus in 2015 he
told The Hollywood Reporter that he
looked back fondly at working with the
interesting people he met during the
height of his Showbiz career as he puts
it I have absolutely no regrets
whatsoever my life is wonderful after
Rick Moranis passed on Ice Ventura
producers looked to Jim Carrey's In
Living Color cast mate David Alan Grier
which Greer revealed during a 2019
appearance on the Howard Stern Show he
also noted that they considered Rob
Schneider who was a cast member on
Saturday Night Live at the time after
reading the script though gria didn't
see a box of his head so he passed
besides Moranis and kriya the producers
also considered Whoopi Goldberg Judd
Nelson and Alan Rickman once Kerry got
involved he helped shape the character
and script alongside fighter director
Tom shadyak as Kerry explained to the
Los Angeles Times in 1994 from the
beginning of my involvement I said that
the character had to be rock and roll I
wanted to be unstoppably ridiculous and
they'd let me go wild this movie was
going to either be something that people
really went for or it was going to ruin
me completely
alrighty there Lauren Holly began her
acting career on TV in the 80s on a
couple episodes of the Cub drama Hill
Street Blues Before making your way to
the soap opera All My Children Jim
Carrey lobbied for her to play the part
of Melissa in Ace Ventura but she turned
that down because of scheduling
conflicts with her ongoing role on the
show Picket Fences Melissa was
ultimately played by Courtney Cox
instead then in 1995 Holly admitted to
Entertainment Weekly I kicked myself
when it came out Holly eventually got
another chance to co-star with Kerry
later that year in Dumb and Dumber and
she said of that movie the minute I
heard it was Jim and Jeff I definitely
wanted to be a part of it I think my
hardest job is just to keep a straight
face and not ruin any of the takes
believe me that's tough Holly and Kerry
fell in love for making Dumb and Dumber
and got married in 1996 after Kerry's
divorce from his first marriage was
finalized alas their Union lasted less
than a year Jim Carrey Jeff Daniels and
Lauren Holly were the perfect stars for
Dumb and Dumber but they weren't the
lineup that the studio originally
envisioned as recounted by E news
Newland Cinema felt that they were
taking a chance in letting the novice
fairly Brothers direct their own
screenplay so they wanted to be closely
involved in the casting process Martin
Short was supposedly new Line's first
pick for Lloyd but he ultimately turned
down the part he hasn't spoken publicly
about that decision but vulture
speculated that he may have been
apprehensive about starring in the debut
comedy of two directors with no track
record Bobby Farrelly later told The
Hollywood Reporter that they were trying
to cast the movie for a couple of years
but they kept getting turned down by
everyone Peter thoroughly added in that
same interview that in reality many of
the actors weren't actually being
informed of the offers by their agents
as he puts it it's so hard to tell how
many actually passed but we were told
100.
so you're telling me there's a chance
Martin shorts wasn't the only big time
comedian to turn down the Farrelly
brothers or even the only big time
comedian with Martin in his name as his
longtime collaborator and friend Steve
Martin also declined the role of dumb
and dumb as Lloyd his work in films like
the jerk and Three Amigos made him an
obvious choice but he was seriously in
demand at the time so the competition to
cast him was fierce eventually though
one of The Producers got a script over
to Jim Carrey and he responded favorably
as Peter farrelli would call to The
Hollywood Reporter when we met with him
he was like he got it exactly like we
got it and so we thought this guy would
be perfect for it when Kerry signed on
Ace Ventura Pet Detective hadn't come
out yet so contract negotiations became
an issue when their star we negotiated
his salary after scoring big at the box
office earlier in the year after locking
down Kerry as Lloyd the focus was then
shifted to figuring out who would play
Harry new line reportedly wasn't
initially interested in casting Jeff
Daniels as Bobby thoroughly noted to The
Hollywood Reporter Daniels was not the
obvious choice because he hadn't done
any you know out and out comedies before
that after they read together Kerry
lobbied for Daniels to get the role and
the latter accepted the offer against
his agents advice and that a discounted
pay rate
before carrion Daniels and before
everyone else they considered the
Pharaoh leads reportedly originally
envisioned Nicholas Cage and Gary Oldman
as Lloyd and Harry and Dumb and Dumber
cage confirmed this in 2012 when he told
the Huffington Post that he was indeed
in talks with Kerry whom he starred
alongside in 1986's Peggy Sue got
married but cage ultimately turned the
role down so that he could instead star
in Leaving Las Vegas for which he ended
up winning an Oscar years later Kate had
another opportunity to book a part that
eventually went to Kerry again in 2017
director Michelle gandry told The Daily
Beast that he approached cage to play
jaw in 2004's Eternal Sunshine of the
Spotless Mind before ultimately choosing
to cast Kerry against type after cage
became an Oscar winner at the
competition to cast him in an
independent film was quite stiff gandry
also told Vanity Fair that watching
Kerry on the set of 2003's Bruce
Almighty convinced him that he could
handle the role because he saw something
lonely behind his comedic facade
that's how I praise
Robin Williams is all set to play The
Joker in 1989's Batman but he ultimately
lost the part to Jack Nicholson who went
on to make quite the impression as the
clown Prince of Crime Williams felt that
Warner Brothers had used him as bait to
Lord Nicholson and he was disappointed
to lose thousand a role he believed he
would have been perfect for despite that
setback he maintained hopes of
eventually playing a Batman villain in a
2015 interview at The Hollywood Reporter
Batman Forever screenwrites her lead
Bachelor revealed that they actually
wrote The Riddler with William's voice
in mind and back in 1993 Entertainment
Weekly reported that Williams was
excited to read the script but he
eventually turned down the role without
offering any public comment about why he
declined as an Insider told ew he
believed the character was too
intellectual and not as comedic as a
riddler played by Frank gorshin on the
TV series others suggested that Williams
was wary of Warner Brothers after what
happened with The Joker either way after
he turned down the role Kerry was
eventually cast as a riddler but
Williams was still interested in playing
the character in Christopher for Nolan's
version of the franchise selling Empire
in 2012
ought to play The Riddler in the next
Batman although it'd be hard to top
Heath as a villain and I'm a little
hairy for tights believe it or not Chris
Farley was the first actor attached to
1996's the Cable Guy before Jim Carrey
came into the picture as reported by
variety after Colombia pictures bought
the script that cast Farley to star in
the title Roar unfortunately though
Paramount Pictures still had the comic
character assigned to a two movie deal
and he had to film Black Sheep to
fulfill that contract Farley and
Colombia agreed that he could film The
Cable Guy after finishing out his stint
as a cast member on Saturday Night Live
[Music]
son of them that's gonna leave a mark
But Folly ultimately dropped out to the
project because he reportedly didn't
want to be locked into anything so far
in the future sadly both his career and
life were cut short when he died at the
age of 33 in December 1997. Kerry's turn
and the Cable Guy wound up being a
performance that changed Hollywood
Forever he was on a career high coming
off as multiple hits in 1994 and he
negotiated a 20 million dollar Payday
for the dark comedy as reported by
variety he was the first actor to
command a salary of that size looking
back in 2021 variety deals reporter Mike
Fleming Jr noted every major top of the
line movie star got a 5 million dollar
raise at the time Carrie's payday was
bigger news and the Cable Guy itself
which failed to really click at the box
office though it's since become a cult
favorite
1998's The Truman Show predicted the
shift towards our reality TV culture
with a bold story about a man who
doesn't know that he's the star of a
show about his own life the movie gave
Jim Carrey a rare opportunity to take on
a more serious role which would lead to
more dramatic opportunities down the
road
I don't see you good afternoon good
evening
as reported by variety Kerry wanted the
opportunity to Branch out and show his
range so badly that he even took a pay
cut making only 12 million dollars
instead of his typical 20 million dollar
fee director Peter Weir was so set on
Kerry taking the lead role that he
waited a year to film because the actor
was busy making liar liar and the Cable
Guy although this might make it sound
like we knew exactly who he wanted in
his cast there was still a last minute
shake-up as Dennis Harper was actually
originally set up to play the antagonist
Christoph Butz has reported by the Los
Angeles Times after just one day of
shooting Hopper left a production due to
creative differences and was later
replaced by Ed Harris as Harris recalled
to The Hollywood Reporter in 2021 they
were shooting a scene in Malibu and I
live in Malibu so I drove up the coast
to meet with Peter we talked it was a
Friday I think I started work on Monday
in April 2010 the rap reported that Ben
Stiller was talking to director Noah
boneback about starring in the title
role of the adaptation of the children's
book Mr Popper's Penguins their
interpretation of the project was a
little bizarre and included an entirely
new storyline with football player
Peyton Manning and his real estate agent
two months later it was reported that
Stiller had walked away from the role
and bound back ultimately passed on the
project it seemed that a big part of the
appeal for the actor was a chance to
work with his frequent collaborator
again afterwards the likes of Jack Black
and Owen Wilson were on the short list
of actors that the studio was interested
in casting but Jim Carrey was at the top
of their list once Mark Waters came on
board as a director he called up Kerry
in the hopes that he would star they've
been trying to work together for a while
and Kerry was the only person he could
see in the role as Waters told
Entertainment Weekly I got lucky I asked
for Jim and I got him although Waters
was thrilled to work with Gary the movie
was ultimately typically received by
critics and didn't do very well at the
box office either
foreign
[Music]